genesis chapter 1
reading verse 14
the bible says and god said
let there be lights in the firmament of
the heaven to divide the day from the
night
let them be for signs and for seasons
and days and years
and let them be for lights in the
firmament of the heaven to give light
upon the earth and it was so
in that verse in that passage
we have two very very fundamental
concepts
expressed one is
existence and the other one
is purpose and god said
let there be lights in the firmament of
the heaven
that is existence god is bringing
something into existence
and then he says to divide the day from
the night
that is the purpose
why they were brought into existence
now the purpose logically
precedes the existence
in other words god has something in mind
and it exists in his mind with all the
fine
and precise details as it subsequently
exists
when it takes on physical form and shape
and
its three-dimensionality it is complete
in the mind of god god needed
a form a source of light for the heavens
and the sun and the moon and the stars
were here
before they were there so that when god
said let there be lights
there was nothing haphazard about the
appearance of the light
the light was already here and the
source the form
of that light was already done here and
then god by the spoken word
gave expression to what was up here
the purpose was formed i want these
bodies
to give light and then he gave
existence to the sun
the moon and the stars
so when god saw that it was good what
god
saw was that what was here
is precisely what appeared out here
are you following me
that made it good
god always has a purpose
in mind he does nothing
just for the sake of doing it
god is an orderly god as i've said so
many times
he's a god of purpose god who goes from
cause to effect
those are the principles he has placed
in the universe and god does not
high-handedly violate his own principles
in genesis chapter 1 verse 26
the bible says and god said let us make
man in our image
after our likeness let them have
dominion over the fish of the sea and
over the fowl of the air
of the cattlemen of all the earth and
over every creeping thing that creepeth
upon the earth
now here again we have purpose
and we have existence and i hope you're
following me
resist any urge to chat
let us make man
that's existence in our image
that's the purpose
this means if we go back to the sun moon
and stars
they do one thing
in a context of god's plan for creation
and that is to do what
give light
that's the major function of the sun the
moon
the stars they give light they also
manage the division of the seasons let
them be for days and for years
for seasons so they do that that's what
they do
when god came to the creation of man he
was also very precise
about the purpose for mankind
and the purpose is wrapped up in a very
few words
three words in our
image
we have no other purpose for being on
this earth
no other purpose i should say
that originates with god
now god's people find all kinds of
purposes that god did not have in mind
but god's purpose from creation
until now is that we would reflect
his image
what's god's image god's image is what
moses saw when god hit him in the rock
merciful longsuffering
gracious plenteous in mercy
not pardoning the guilty forgiving the
penitent
that is god's image
along with creativity a sense of order
that's god's image progress
development to a particular goal
the image of god that's
the reason god made us
we are here
to reflect his image that was the
purpose
now that purpose was in god's mind
before
adam and eve were made
see the purpose has to be established
it's clear
then god said having the purpose clear
in his mind
this is why i want them to exist
then god gave them life
why why
to carry out the purpose
and no other reason
let me repeat that we
breathe we live
from god's perspective for one reason
only
that is to reflect the image of god
in all that we do adam
in working in the garden to dress it and
keep it was to reflect the image of god
of course god also gave him dominion
which is also a reflection of god
because god has ultimate dominion over
the entire universe
and david tells us in second samuel 23
verse 4
he that ruleth over men must be just
ruling in the fear
of god he that hath dominion must be
just exercising that dominion
in the fear of god being always
conscious if i'm a supervisor over here
in the department
of pediatrics i must exercise that
supervisory responsibility
with the consciousness that i have a
supervisor in the department of eternity
and i'm answerable to him
with the invention with the introduction
of sin one of the greatest curses people
can have
is to have power over other people
but when god gave adam dominion adam was
unfallen and adam was supposed to
exercise
that dominion the way god
himself would do it because an image
its purpose is to reflect
and to bring to mind a higher
a perfect original
this also means and if i may say it's
some embarrassment to all of us
we exist for no purpose that comes from
us
we exist for no purpose that is of our
invention i know it's extreme
but it is true all that we're supposed
to do
and me must be traced back to genesis 1
26 and 27.
god's image have dominion
that's the reason why god gave us
existence and our existence
how we use it must be a perfect match
with god's purpose so that god can see
that it is what
good
having said that when god looked at our
lives today and what we have chosen to
do with them
can god say very good
but we have to shake his head and say
that's not what i had in mind
for that son of mine he has gone
the way of the world and has drifted
from my original design
when jesus was on this earth he never
lost sight
of the purpose that brought him
and people were always trying to get him
to go to the right or to the left do one
thing or the other and
christ was stabilized by the
consciousness
of his purpose it was a consciousness
that never slept
so man spoke to him in luke chapter 12
master and one of the companies said to
him master
speak to my brother that he divide the
inheritance with me
and he said unto him man who made me a
judge
or a divider over you
what is jesus saying that i don't care
if your brother is selfish no
christ is saying my purpose
is not to settle inheritance issues
and we need to be very clear what our
purposes are
or we will be pulled in a thousand
different directions to please people
by god's conviction
and the witness of other people
my purpose in life is to do what i do
you offer me the presidency of the
general conference
and i will tell you no thanks
and i've told god the only way i would
accept an administrative position in any
organization
is to use my influence to make sure that
the entire structure under my
administration
aligns itself with god's purpose for
seventh-day adventists
other than that i don't want it my
purpose
is to stand right where i'm standing
and i will not let anyone offer me
anything
that deflects me from the path
of the purpose god has made known to me
we all have the same common purpose in
the sense we reflect the image of god
but god requires that reflection in
different
paths for different people
for you it may be medical work
for someone else it may be architecture
for someone else a primary school
teacher
the vital question isn't whether it's
doctor dentist
lawyer the vital question is have i
taken into my soul
the reality originating from heaven that
i
am on this earth not for any purpose of
my own but for god's
when that is in me then god can direct
me
in the path along which i must reflect
his image
so god has given to every one of us
life to carry out an individualized
purpose
take two ministers and god has purposes
that are different one from the other
even though they're both preaching his
purposes are different
god has an individualized approach to
his creatures
let me repeat god has given each one of
us a life
to carry out a purpose now the most
important thing to us
to us must be the preservation
the integrity of that purpose in our
lives
having said that take the preacher the
evangelist
it should be our desire to carry out
that purpose
as long as we possibly can
until the ultimate goal which is
everything brought back under god's
control in the person of jesus christ
until that comes to be our desire should
be lord
give me life that i may work and work
and work as someone said i'm sorry i
don't have i only have one life to give
for my country
we must be sorry we have just one life
to give for god
but if god says i'll give you 70 years
to carry out my purpose
then in the interest of that purpose
that god shows
should we not protect the quality of our
lives
does not the purpose of god benefit more
if i'm healthy
than if i'm always sick
god has something for me to do i repeat
tediously he hasn't
this is the path for randy skeet
and i'm on it but i can't get very far
because i'm always sick
and sickness is a violation
of the laws that god has put in place
that we may remain in prime condition
to carry out his purpose
and so god's purpose for me
suffers because i am sickly
and i am sickly because of my sin
or someone else's sin or both
my desire for health must not be so i
can
live a long time to see my children grow
up
that's good that cannot be my primary
reason for wanting to be healthy
my primary reason for good health cannot
be so i can work hard and accumulate
among efforts of money that cannot be my
primary motivation
my primary motivation must be i preserve
my health for two fundamental reasons
because if i'm healthy
i can do god's work well and a healthy
body
is a part is also a reflection
of the character of jesus christ
otherwise jesus was never sick
matthew 8 17 after he healed those who
had been demon-possessed
that it might be fulfilled himself took
our infirmities
and bear our sicknesses
the gospel deals with disease
of the body as it deals with disease
of the soul
and so some of us are sick today
i'll ask you one of my regular questions
and don't answer me
why are we sick is it the smog
in what i think someone told me is
called the basin of los angeles
is it the absence of clean water
to drink or is it overwork
jesus said work while it is what
day
the night cometh where no man can work
i don't want to reflect on doctors who
have a life-saving work to do
let me exempt them temporarily
some people work two jobs one in the day
one at night the night
was god's choice for a time
to sleep
jesus said work while it is day
the night cometh why does he use that
symbolism because he was the one who
arranged
the evening and the morning were the
first day
and the dark part of the day is sleeping
time when we
violate that law the body
suffers and sometimes it
suffers beyond the point of recovery
because no law of god however seemingly
insignificant
can be broken with impunity
just does not happen the scripture the
bible says john 10 35
cannot be broken
we need to make a pledge today
because god's power is not a band-aid
for our disobedience
if we think that we are dealing very
unfairly with god
we need to make a pledge that we will
indeed
by his grace heighten and intensify
our awareness that this the physical
and the mental has been entrusted to us
entrusted to us
for the carrying out of god's purpose
health is a sacred matter
it is not a matter of the vitamin
industry it is a sacred
biblical concept
that's why we read in revelation 21
verse 4
and god shall wipe away all tears from
their eyes
there shall be no more death not a
sorrow
nor crying neither shall there be any
more pain
what is the pain of cancer the pain of
rheumatoid arthritis
the pain of some degenerated disc in the
lower back
the pain of whatever it is no more pain
because god wants us to get back to the
original
you know jesus believed in the original
the book is closed meaning i'm about to
finish
the pharisees came to him in matthew 19
lord is it lawful to put away
thy wife for every cause
jesus said to them
hast thou not read that he which
made them at the beginning
made them male and female and said for
this call shall a manly father and
mother and shall be joined to his wife
and they shall be and the twin shall be
one flesh
wherefore they are no more twain but one
flesh what therefore god have joined
together let no man put asunder
then they came back why did moses then
command to give her a writing of
divorcement and to put her away
jesus said to them moses because of the
hardness of your heart
suffered you to put away your wives but
from the beginning
twice he takes them back to the
beginning
because god's arrangement in the
beginning before the corruption of sin
his desire is to restore
that original arrangement god has always
had his eyes
on the ideal it has not changed
that's why revelation 21 1 and i saw a
new heaven
and a new earth the first one that was
corrupted
passed away and god goes back to the
original ideal
no sin no sickness
even though we live in a sinful world we
must live by the principles of the ideal
because that's what jesus did when he
was appealed to
to settle a question about divorce jesus
said you go back to the way it was and
you'll find your hands that's why he
said
hast thou not read
don't you read patriarchs and prophets
jesus said
don't you read genesis
hast thou not read question don't answer
me
do you read
many questions that adventists ask many
of them not all
many are the result of the fact
we don't read
so we don't know but let me leave that
aside and conclude
by reminding us
we are here for a purpose
the purpose is summed up in three words
in our image
and having settled that purpose in his
mind
god brought adam and eve into existence
for the carrying out of that purpose
jesus kept his purpose always before him
and as i led you to luke 12 13 to 14
when the man said speak to my brother
that he divide the inheritance with me
he said to him verse 14 of luke 12 man
who made me a judge
or a divider over you now
jesus knew what his father had made him
by assigning him a responsibility he
came
to reveal the father that was his task
god made him that
if i may express it that way god didn't
send him to settle disputes about
inheritance so jesus said who made me a
judge you
you no i can't let you decide what i'm
here to do
you settle that
next question don't answer me whatever
you are professionally
who made you then
god or the customs of society
god or the irresistible impulses of the
culture
who made you who you are
professionally
jesus was clear i was not sent to be a
judge
or for you or a divider that's not my
work
the work you and i do is that
the work god originally had for
us
attached to the reflection of his image
or is the work we do
an expression of our conformity to what
society says
is necessary to have a certain status
and to occupy
a certain socio-economic niche
i'm asking don't answer me
the line of study you're currently
contemplating
is it in line with god's purpose for you
or is it in line with what most people
do
i suspect we have no idea how
drastically
we have drifted from the purpose
god had for us
assuming with generosity that all of us
are engaged in activities that are
perfectly
in conformity with god's will for us and
that's why he gave us life
let us pledge to preserve our health
that we might for as long as we can
carry out that purpose
and so we will pray and tell god
father i believe
that the reason i chose the work i do
had nothing to do with reflecting your
image
in the honesty and the privacy of my
heart i conclude their father that the
reasons that drove me to chose to choose
it
were secular economic
cultural and social and not heavenly
we will bow our heads
we will also ask god to forgive us for
the habits
that have compromised the health he has
given to us
as an as a a an investment a treasure an
inheritance something we must protect
we will tell him we are sorry for the
practices
that have damaged our health
giving the universe the wrong view of
what a
redeemed person should look like and how
that person should live we'll tell god
we're sorry
we'll tell him that and after we've done
that
we'll slip quietly into the other part
of the surface
wherever you can if there's room between
the rose we want to kneel
and i'll give you two minutes now two
minutes may feel like a long time
but two minutes to pray that prayer of
confession to god
and then i will pray audibly then we'll
move into the second part of the service
and we want to pray quietly when you're
done please don't talk to your neighbor
maintain a respectful silence
in the presence of god
um
our father in heaven we come to you as
your children
to admit that we have been rebellious
stubborn stiff-necked
and hypocritical we have come lord
because despite the way we treat you
you will not let us go and we cannot
understand that stubborn love that you
have
for a people that do not deserve it
but surely father the stubbornness of
your love must be connected to the fact
that
somewhere in your heart like jesus
telling peter when that would
convert his strength in the brethren you
must somewhere think that we will
finally come around
and so you persist in holding on
in your mind to the original purpose you
had for us
as a church and as individuals
and father we want to align ourselves
now with that
expectation you have which is that we
will live in obedience to your law
we will treasure and protect your image
that what we reflect
would be perfect and reliable to those
looking on
father in very few areas
are we more irresponsible than in the
way we treat our bodies
which then affects our mind
and we've come to say that we have been
we have broken the principles of health
and for that reason many of us cannot
appreciate spiritual things because the
condition of the body
affects how the mind works and the
sharpness of the mind
and so precious truths lord are lost to
us
or hidden because the mind is so
numb and so so blunted by the abuse that
the body suffers
we believe according to first
corinthians 3 16
that our temples our bodies are the
temples of the holy spirit
lord we want to believe that with all
our hearts
so that the same way we take great care
of our churches and make them look like
palaces
we may take care of our bodies where you
actually dwell
father none of us claims to be better
than the other
but we kneel in support of one another
and we say as a group and as individuals
forgive us we're sorry
place upon our hearts a conviction that
will not leave us from this day on
that we will be careful what goes into
this body
we will be careful what we do with how
we spend our time the kinds of
recreation in which we engage
that sometimes do more harm than good
and father we will guard how we spend
our time
we will take time to rest because we are
people of the sabbath
father we're grateful that you're a god
of mercy if you were not we would have
been destroyed a long time ago
and so we pause now to praise your name
for being a good god
you are merciful you are righteous
you are gracious you are long suffering
you're so
kind you are so generous father
and we have no complaints about you
you're innocent of any wrongdoing in our
lives all you've ever done for us is try
your perspiring best to bless us
but we have blocked your blessings by
our rebellion and we're sorry
we accept psalm 145 verse 17 the lord is
righteous in
all his ways and holy
in all his works now lord as we move
into this
service let your spirit linger
jealously to be close to us let the
angels at
excellent strength be here to keep obey
the forces of darkness
and let your name be glorified in the
spiritual and physical healing you will
choose to place
in the lives of your people keep us ever
mindful
that when spiritual healing comes to a
person
physical healing begins to follow
hear us because we come in the name of
someone you cannot resist
and that is your son and our brother and
savior we pray this prayer
in his name and for that sake we offer
it with confidence
and we thank you for hearing us amen
while we are
conducting the service which will be
brief
i urge you to maintain a spirit of
reverence
when i came in this morning for the 11
o'clock service
i could not believe the level of noise
that was here
perhaps more important than recapturing
health is we're capturing
a sense of god's reverence and
is his sacredness
we walk into a courtroom and we are
quiet
because we know that man or that woman
in that black
coat and with one wave of a hand
that woman or that man can have that
officer put you in a cell
if your cell phone goes off in that
courtroom
god is the judge of all the earth that's
what abraham said genesis chapter 18
verse 25
shall not the judge of all the earth do
right we are in
his presence i say again from my heart
not in condemnation because i have to
watch myself
we treat god's presence
so lightly we chat
we talk i was preaching in some country
far away
in the middle of the sermon sermon a
woman's cell phone went off she answered
conducted a conversation then hang up
and
then resumed i suppose listening to me
so i'm appealing to you reverence
in the presence of god i don't want to
preach to sermons
but it just makes sense to me
if you want someone to do something for
you
be nice to that person
it works with god
it works with god we are disrespectful
we have no reverence we're noisy in his
house we run up and down
we don't manage our children in god's
house and then we say lord bless me
i've said before god is not an atm
machine
you pop in a card of convenience and out
comes a blessing then you turn your back
and you go
let's be referent are there any pastors
in the congregation
any elders
come my dear brother please come help
i just want some to stand with me on
either side and i want some to do some
reading for me my bible is right here in
the desk
could someone reposition a microphone
for
right here so that we can have the god's
word read
while we're doing what we're doing and
with the reading of the word i also want
there to be prayers
all through this building spiritual
services like this are not spectator
sports they are
opportunities to interact with god i
will ask
my dear brother would you do some
reading for us we want to read
exodus chapter 20 the 10 commandments
read from verse 1 to verse 17.
when he's done my good brother would you
go read revelation chapter 14
and when he's done would you go read
isaiah
58 in that order
and then when he's done i'd like you to
begin
reading the sermon on the mount chapter
five
and if we're not done then i want you to
take
chapter six of the book of matthew the
sermon on the mount
and we read until it is done i'd like a
lady who functions as the deaconess to
come and assist me
to uncover the table are there any
deaconesses present
come sister please
just come and join us then we'll pray
every head bowed every eye closed
father forgive us for irreverence
and for being disrespectful in your
presence
we apologize and we really do
sometimes we just need to be reminded
preachers in the pulpit
and members in the pew so accept our
apology i pray from my heart i speak for
my brothers and sisters
our lord show us your favor by smiling
upon this service
now lord i dedicate the symbol of the
holy spirit to you
as loy says the oil is a symbol of the
work of the spirit on our hearts
that's where healing must begin in the
heart
now be with us i pray and let everything
be done
to your glory and to our benefit
in jesus name amen
you take it
i have been asking us to make some
spiritual preparation
one you've sinned against someone
confess to that person two someone has
wronged you tell the person
i forgive you three
something in your life you know is sin
confess it
which means admit repent which means go
in the opposite direction
and seek daily grace hourly grace
momently grace if i can say that
to live apart from that sin and then of
course some of us
are fasting that was optional if you
have made
the first three of the four preparations
and only if you've done that
i want you to stand
all right they're not too many of us so
that's good
i will ask those on this side
to just form a line in the aisle just
slip out and form a straight line
in the aisle
and form the line close to these chairs
right here
form the line that's right so when you
return you have an empty path to get
back to your seat
form the line on that side that's right
that's right
and those i want you praying you may
begin the reading god bless you
what we will do we will pray
i will pray
our father in heaven we're on our knees
again
bowing before you
having confessed our violation of your
principles of health
which amounts to a violation of your
spiritual principles
we bow fathers i speak for me and my
brothers and sisters to say we have not
treated you well at
all
again father we cannot say enough how
sorry we are regardless of physical
healing or not
lord what we want is a close walk with
you and we need to
understand that a close walk with you
includes how we treat this temple you
gave to us
which is where you want to live and you
cannot live
in untidy surroundings
and so father we pray that you would be
merciful to us
first by opening our eyes to
see the intimate connection
between spiritual health and physical
health
the connection between victory over sin
and
physical health the connection between
understanding divine things
and spiritual health
lord your servant says and patriarchs
and prophets page 45
man was to bear god's image
both in outward resemblance and
in image father when we're sick and
sickly and do we fully bear your image
in outward resemblance
and when we damage our spiritual lives
do we bear your image
in character and so father we say we're
sorry again we believe you heard us the
first time
but the depth of our pain drives us to
say one more time we are
sorry and now father
we pray in the name of jesus that you
would be
the god of your word you've said in
exodus 15 26 if thou will diligently
hearken to the voice of the lord thy god
and will do that which is right in his
sight
and keep his commandments and give ear
to all his statutes
i will put none of these diseases upon
you that i have brought upon the
egyptians i am the law that healeth thee
lord today we want you to be a healing
god
you've said in psalm 103 verse 3 who
forgiveth
all our iniquities who healeth all our
diseases
father you said all in both statements
in that verse
lord you said in james 5 14 to 16
is any sick among you let him call for
the elders of the church and let them
pray over him
anointing him with oil in the name of
the lord and the prayer of faith shall
receive the sick
and the lord shall raise him up and if
he have committed sins they shall be
forgiven him
we have confessed now we plead for
healing father because
the sickness causes aches and pains
lord if you will give us health we will
take that strength and give it to your
cause
father have mercy on us as jesus
laid his hand on every miserable sick
person who came to him
and he laid it in mercy not only for
physical reasons but to teach spiritual
lessons help us to learn the spiritual
lesson that you will be giving us
in the physical healing we pray for and
we want to receive with all the faith
that we have
father whatever you do we praise your
name
we say like job if you slay us we will
trust you
if you heal us we will trust you but
father you've also invited us to tell us
what we tell you what we want
and what we want is remove our
afflictions
remove our diseases remove the
conditions that us and weakness
and make us
almost useless to your cause
do this for us now we pray and let us
use your miracle
as a reason to testify that god is a
merciful god because you are hear this
humble prayer
and let us exit this place of people
determined to obey you
in everything you say not as fanaticism
but as an expression as our love for you
hear us bless us restore us
heal us and may your image be more
clearly revealed in us
we pray and we thank you for hearing us
in
jesus name and for his sake let all
god's people say
amen and amen you may stand
or return to your seats
i want just to have one final reading
quietly
i know you have things to do but our
greatest desire should be spiritual
things
my dear elder who's walking away would
you come back
right here he's walking away tell him
come back let's do one final reading for
us please
just read the beatitudes matthew 5 1
2 18 19.
let's listen carefully to god's word as
it is read
matthew five one
two let's say one two one two sixteen
sixteen
and please follow along in your bibles
and try to develop
a love for hearing
the word of god
and then we pray and we go always aware
that the sun has not yet set
father in heaven we love you
we just love you and we thank you
you have always loved us we leave this
place with your love in our hearts
we want you to know father in heaven
that
we will try by your grace
to take what we've gotten from this
service with us
and make it a part of our lives we will
try their god by your grace
one day at a time one meal at a time
to honor you by preserving the health
you've given to us father
we will do what we can by your grace
to make sure that the image we reflect
is not the image of the beast but the
image of jesus christ
himself lord we're happy
and we say with the psalmist in psalm 34
1 i will bless the lord at
all times his praise shall continually
be in my mouth
father let our mouths be filled with
your praise wherever we go
thank you for being god thank you for
blessing us
we praise your name and we thank you in
jesus name
amen god bless you god bless you
be faithful unto death and god
will give us a crown of life